مع قدوم موسم الاعياد والعطله المدرسيه
اختار بعض الاطباء في القطاع الخاص في
فرنسا اغلاق عياداتهم لمده اسبوع احتجاج
على الظروف عملهم ضاربين عرض الحائط حاجه
الناس الى العلاج في هذه الفتره الحرجه من
السنه ولقد تسبب هذا الاضراب بالضغط على
المستشفيات وايضا على بقيه الاطباء الذين
فضلوا ابقاء عياداتهم مفتوحه لاستقبال
مرضى الحالات المستعجله كحال هذا الطبيب
العام الذي بقي على راس عمله عامل
اللازم يعني بدل ما المريض يوقف من دون
موعد على الانتظار يعني ساعتين مثلا يوقف
ثلاث ساعات كم هائل بالنسبه للعيادات
الخاصه وبالنسبه ايضا للمشاكل الحكوميه
انا ما مع اي اضرار
اذا كان همم يؤثر على المواطن بشكل مباشر
ويطالب الاطباء المحتجون بمضاعفه
الاستشاره الصحيه 25 الى 50 يورو لتشجيع
الطلاب على هذه المهنه بعد ان تسبب عزوفهم
عنها بما يسمى بالتصحر الطبي اي بالنقص في
عدد الاطباء خصوصا في الارياف والذي يعوده
عدد من الاطباء المهاجرين الرواتب للاطباء
العاملين في القطاع الصحي سواء اطباء او
ممرضات يعني لم تتغير منذ حواري 20 عام
اضف الى ذلك مشكله التضخم الذي نشهدها
الان في كل العالم حتى ان نتيجه هذا
التصحر الطبي وهذه المطالب المشروعه التي
ادت الى عدد كبير منهم الى ترك عمل الهام
ادى ذلك الى زياده الضغط العامل على
النسبه التي بقيت في المستشفيات وكانت
الحكومه الفرنسيه قد ضاعت الاطباء
المطربين الى تحمل المسؤولياتهم والعوده
الى العمل خاصه مع استمرار ازمه كوفي
وانتشار امراض معديه اخرى في هذه الفتره
الحرجه من السنه خلال الاعياد والعطله
المدرسيه ان شاء الله اضراب والاطباء
المؤسسات الصحيه مس ضغطا كبيرا على
المستشفيات خاصه في ظل ارتفاع حالات
الاصابه بكورونا والانفلونزا الموسميه
زينه عدي العربيه باريس